[Music]
one week until the nfl draft that is
right we are seven days away until the
jacksonville jaguars are on the clock
with the number one overall pick for the
consecutive year i'm connor rogers the
lead nfl draft analyst here at bleacher
report joined as always by stadium's
college football analyst michael felder
today we got safeties we got corners we
got the nfc south but before that we got
some prophet action to talk about as
well felder how we feeling man i know
you love the show where we go over the
dvs
yeah listen i mean this this show
couldn't be more in my wheelhouse right
we're talking obviously we're going to
get to the prop bets there in a second
but we're talking about defensive backs
i'm a former defensive back so i love
that part of it but we're also hey man
nfc south you know where i'm from hey
represent baby 704 i'm from charlotte so
listen i know i know these teams these
are this is my division so we got a lot
of stuff to get to uh let's kick it off
with prop bets and let's start with
jermaine johnson because conor the
question i wanted to kick to you is
why is he on a guy that we're talking
about as a fringe top 10 guy but travon
trayvon walker from georgia people are
viewing him as a top four pick
yeah right it's a great question because
when you look at jermaine johnson the
double-digit sack season something that
trayvon walker never had in college he
didn't even get above seven uh and you
look at just overall the impact that he
made on games jermaine johnson was a
difference maker now with trayvon
walkerfelder you're betting on that
elite length and athleticism and what
teams deem versatility they think he can
play three tech on passing downs a lot
of teams going for fourth down right now
you need guys that can kick inside and
wreak havoc against guards and then they
think on early downs he'll be able to
play true defensive end five tech maybe
even rush wide but that would surprise
me that's a lot of projecting there so
jermaine johnson trayvon walker's rise
has maybe hurt jermaine johnson but i
think at the end of the day he's going
to be a top 10 pick felder where are you
at the end of the day with your main
johnson
i'm going to pick him i'm going to go i
think he goes in the top 10. and the
question becomes what happens at the
quarterback spot he's not in charge of
where he gets drafted i think that's the
part that people have to remember uh
this is a guy that i think has had as
you mentioned a meteoric rise uh the big
thing for me is he can do all this stuff
that you mentioned he can play a five he
can play he can kick down to a three as
well if you want to put them in a sub
package where you've got a racer uh
coming off the edge uh so like if if if
you're a team that gets jermaine johnson
and nick bonito and you put both of
those guys kick him down inside why not
do that so i'm looking forward to it uh
connor we got to talk wide receivers
though too
yeah we got two of them right here right
that are fringe top 10 guys in a wide
receiver class everybody's trying to
figure out
who's going to be the first one and then
how many are going to go early not just
top 20 but now top 15 and of course
we're looking at the top 10 we got
jameson williams and drake london and
we'll start with jamison williams belder
i have a pretty consistent rule when
looking at draft betting and predictions
speed always goes first and that's what
jameson williams has now will he be
drafted over garrett wilson or drake
london the acl tear is what can hold him
back from that but will he be drafted
early yes top 10 though a little rich
because it's an early ta it's a very
heavy tackle class heavy pass rush class
we've talked about the quarterbacks
before potentially sneaking in
especially at six to carolina we'll get
to a little bit of that later today
jameson williams i'm out on him in the
top ten but when you look at drake
london because of that size profile the
new york jets all over that i think the
atlanta falcons i would not rule them
out at eight i like drake london in the
top ten jameson williams won't be
waiting long but for drake london he
feels like a lock to make it in the back
end of the top ten where are you at with
both of these players do you think both
can make it in
i think they both can't make it in when
we obviously we're watching drake london
right now and this is a guy that was on
pace to catch one like 150 footballs
before his injury because we do have to
mention he's also coming off an injury
and i think that matters so the big key
for me though the basketball background
that we've talked about you see him here
being physical out muscling going up and
getting it he's a high point guy i don't
think he's as polished as a route runner
as jameson wins i think jameson williams
is the best wide receiver in this draft
period bar none no qualifiers at all i
think james and williams is the best i
think drake london might be the first
off the board and i will say this
because this is our defensive back show
if you're a defensive back drake london
is more scary than
any other wide receiver in this draft
because you can do everything right and
then he can still beat you and i think
that's the part that teams value so i
think that
drake does find himself in the top ten i
think jameson finds himself outside of
the top 10 but i'm going to tell you
what whoever gets him at 12 or 13 or you
get him at 16 or whatever they're going
to be thrilled with what they get and
those other guys are going to be looking
back like nan and nana booboo like we
got we got we got the
guy yeah i think with jameson it's a
stock that you're going to be really
happy with the growth when he comes back
on the field in the middle of the season
and just explodes you just have to be
okay with that that he's not going to be
100 miles an hour in training camp and
right out of the gate but for teams that
are rebuilding sometimes they can take
that kind of investment all right these
next two guys as we look at the
defensive back show today kyle hamilton
derek stingley jr kyle hamilton once
billed as the best player in this draft
once billed as a guy you could not find
outside the top five of every single
mock trap written
now not a lot to go in the top ten minus
135 tells you that vegas thinks he will
go in the top ten but it's closer to 50
50 than a lot of people realize i know
the washington commanders at 11 are all
over him but that would not satisfy this
bet felder i know you love kyle hamilton
but do you think the lack of value for a
safety traditionally in the draft hurts
his chances to sneak into these first 10
picks
yeah it's it's it's frustrating i was
talking to a former tampa bay bucks gm
mark dominic yesterday actually and
he was like it's a combination of his 40
time and safety's not being valued in
the first round the way that they are
valued because you can get there's so
many good safeties you can get them in
round two round three and so i think
that's going to hurt him and push him
down and then the overvaluation of
quarterbacks is going to hurt him
i think with hamilton though we got to
watch the play can we re-rack the
footage by the way can we show that
again the alabama play where the the
first play on the reel where he gets
wide and goes and makes a play like
that's the speed i don't care what his
40 time is the reality is i want to see
this guy be able to go out and do it
because he knows what's going to happen
before it happens and that's the part
that i love about his game um and i
guess next we have to get to derek
stingley right and stingley becomes
interesting because of the injury
because of the injury history because of
not finishing out the season because of
all these extra things when we get to
derek stingley connor uh do you think
he's a top 10 guy because we know sauce
is probably going to be the first corner
off the board but stingley probably has
more
what's the word i'm looking for that he
has more um
elite traits than sauce gardeners sauce
garner just has a better track record
right
i think that's exactly right i mean we
have really never seen at least in my
lifetime
a guy come in as a true freshman and
have the ball production that derek
stingley had and the fact that he did it
while the team was one of the better
college football teams of the last two
decades
even raised that profile of oh no this
guy is a superstar if he was in that
draft after 2019 he was a lock to be a
top three pick in that trap that's how
good his 2019 was as a true freshman
where you look at the trajectory of his
player profile and go man two more years
he could be one of the greatest corner
prospects we've ever seen unfortunately
it doesn't always go as predicted 2020
was not as good as 2019 in my eyes it
was still a good player there's no doubt
about that but as the program went
downhill a lot of evaluators wondered
was he just not as locked in and then he
tried to play through injury in 2021 he
obviously had to shut it down after
three games and it's a lisp frank injury
it's not a sprained ankle it's not even
a broken leg it's something that uh
we've seen it end guys careers i mean
i'm here in new york i watched a 28 year
old san antonio holmes lose his entire
career to that so derek stingley for me
i look at it and think there's one team
in the top 10 that might take them and i
think it's the seattle seahawks they
have a need at corner but i still think
it's a long shot so minus 110 is
something i would stay away from let's
look at the comments right here uh
they're obviously flying in excited
about the prop bets i see a unicorn next
to kyle hamilton i know that'll make
felder happy hamilton to atlanta says
atl 27-27
that's a good fit and that's one you
have to keep your eye on because atlanta
they're rebuilding they're just looking
for the best possible players there's a
good chance kyle hamilton will be the
best player on the board when they pick
at eight you just have to wonder after
everything that's gone on with calvin
ridley obviously julio jones has not
been there lately they are in dire need
of wide receivers uh one more question
here or a comment rabiondomjet says
jameson williams will be the first wide
receiver off the board all right let's
keep this moving felder you know we got
a lot to do today and speaking of derek
stingley we're gonna get right into it
with the blue chip cornerbacks and i
think
it's not going to transition to derek
stingley it's got a transition to the
man of the hour the man of the year that
would be sauce gardener felder tell the
people how we got here with sauce being
the top projected corner in this draft
after being a what 170 pound no name
recruit coming out of detroit
i mean the guy is he's slick dude like
watch him play he's slick he's not
afraid of physical contact as you see in
the clip right there but i love how he's
got that slinkiness to his game and i
don't think that i don't know what
better way to describe it other than
this like slick sleekness like he is i
mean
the guy's a ferrari and
anytime you put a ferrari out there on
the road you've got an opportunity to
really just go 180 miles an hour and
that's what he does and you see him here
taking the ball to the house he is so
polished so well taught i think that we
have to give like you know credit to
these defensive back coaches and to guys
like luke fickle who are defensive
focused and they want their db's to play
a certain way and he fit into that mold
he played almost exclusively man
coverage at cincinnati and that's the
part that i really love about him is he
understood the scheme fit into the
scheme and sauce got it done
yeah he absolutely did he's the perfect
man cover corner when you look at the
giants at number seven wick martindale
that scheme uh that's going to be an
interesting spot for sauce gardener and
how he fits perfectly just reminds me of
a spider felter he's got these long long
arms he's all over the place crazy range
it's just i look at him and just see a
spider and i loved his mentality talking
to him at the combine all right we
talked about derek stingley for a lot a
quick hitter on him somebody that it's
gone a little bit full circle once a
projected top three pick then falling
out of potentially the top 12 top 15. he
was able to test i think that alleviated
a lot of teams concerns about his health
getting ready to go into rookie mini
camp at the end of the day stingley will
probably go in the top 12 you're looking
at minnesota
as his draft floor so felder final notes
on derek stingling before we get into
some guys that we have not talked a lot
about on this show and we're really
excited to get through today
i love the way stingley plays through
the whistle and so that's the big thing
for me he's the guy that's willing to
tackle i love that we've got tackling
footage of him on here because he's not
just a man guy that was the hardest
thing about saul's gardener footage was
finding things where he's doing
something other than covering a guy and
completely off the screen because the
quarterback doesn't look at him sting's
got some other stuff in there so i love
that so uh connor do you want to go
comments you want to go technicians you
tell me which way you want to go because
there's a lot to unpack here when it
comes to the corners as we get into the
technician back
yeah i was going to keep this train
rolling but carter's going to carter's
going to have us the producer carter's
going to have us dive into the comments
we are men of the people on this show so
let's take a look at the comments uh c
mccullough says drafting sauce for the
name alone yeah i'm with you on that
atl's back in the comments says gardner
best pure cornerback i'm with you on
that sauce is the best corner in this
class i see todd 21 says could kyle
hamilton fall if you were expecting him
to be a top five pick you're gonna be
disappointed but i don't think he's
going to fall out of the top 15. and of
course for felder made you lucas says
look at that beard we will be back in
the comments today but we have a lot of
players to go through and we are not
going to cheat you on this show it is
time to get into the technicians at
cornerback and who better to start with
than washington's trent mcduffie felder
i don't care that he would have some of
the shortest arms for a corner in the
nfl i don't care that he's light i don't
care that he's not six feet tall this
guy is instinctual he knows how to
tackle he loves football he all he does
is uh
breathe eat sleep football and that's
what he cares about he's going to come
in and if you're a zone heavy scheme
like the buffalo bills this guy is going
to be a star for you on the outside on
the inside he even likes taking reps at
safety what have you seen from trent
mcduffie felder
yeah that's the thing i love about him
is his attention to detail obviously you
see him there as a part of the pressure
package there
here you see him
lined up goes in with the motion runs
across this is man coverage and he's
able to cross the entire field still
make a play at the light of scrimmage
that's amazing i love this right here
again tracking across the field he's got
the ability he's not afraid to wrestle
guys down to get him on the ground i
think that with with mcduffie like with
duffy and with um tyler gordon who we're
gonna talk about too two washington
corners we can say all we want about the
jimmy lake experiment as a head coach
the reality of it is is as a defensive
backs coach he is very good
his guys are well taught and they know
what they're supposed to do there's a
reason over the course of what the last
four five years
washington has consistently had guys
from buda baker uh
all
he just consistently get picked because
those guys yes exactly those guys get
picked why because they're well taught
and these guys that's what makes them
fit into the technician realm
yeah they've had an incredible run in
that db room uh and we're gonna keep
that run going because it's time to talk
about kyler gordon the guy that played
across from trent mcduffie
who is you know what felder fascinating
to me because he is so different than
mcduffie in a sense of with mcduffie i
feel like what you see is what you get
and that is sound tackling that is not
measurables but instincts uh just play
is such a polished clean game with kyler
gordon for
the maybe you know
raw instincts or the lack thereof yet
because he's only been a one-year
starter there are moments of brilliance
felder where and you see him right there
come downhill and make a play on the
football i've seen him toe tap the
sideline a catch radius like a wide
receiver
elite athleticism and he does not give
much ground up in terms of those on
paper measurables kyler gordon is not as
pro ready as trent mcduffie but he's
someone that comes in and you give him a
little bit more seasoning right you let
him marinate a little bit he could be a
legit outside number one man-to-man
corner with take away the football
ability
see the thing that's interesting to me
is when i watch those clips when i watch
him play
i'm wondering why he's not playing
safety
because he does a lot of safety things
and so that's an interesting part to me
do you like i think he could be a really
really good safety too
i think he could too because he can run
right and i know that everybody looks at
the combine time and they were
disappointed it wasn't in the four
threes after the hype with his
athleticism i know people close to the
university of washington and he was
genuinely not an excuse not feeling well
that day like really really sick then
you look at the pro day numbers the pro
day was insane the numbers were 80 90th
percentile elite athletes so that's how
you know it's it's no lie it's no myth
that those testing times were
significantly boosted agility drills uh
vertical everything like that so i'm
with you felder he's he's got the size
profile and the athletic profile to not
just be a turn and run corner or
anything like that he can play safety
because of the range he has and you see
the eyes downhill with kylo gordon all
right getting away from the university
of washington for a moment we're going
to look at roger mccreary from auburn
a fascinating player
who was very sticky in the sec now he's
another guy with shorter arms but you
see him right there doesn't really
bother him in coverage the ability to
play the football feller he did such a
good job staying in the hip pocket of
everybody he lined up across from this
here
yeah i think you hit the nail on the
head when you call them sticky right
this is a guy that he's going to be on
you and he's going to be around you and
he's going to be
you know what it's like he's he's going
to be like your little brother that just
is around you all the time and the last
thing that you want is to look over and
see his face but he's just gonna be
around you and he's annoying and it's
it's it's it's he's he's an annoying
corner and annoying is a good thing to
be as a corner because that means that
your stick you've got that
stick-to-itiveness to cover guys across
he can cover guys horizontally across
the field but can also cover guys
vertically up the field and i love that
about him but again he's going to stick
in your hip pocket he is
if i had to pick any of the corners out
of this draft out of this class
he's the guy that has all the little
tricks down better than anyone else he
understands how to grab your back elbow
so that you can help pull him into a in
into into a cut so that he doesn't get
called for pass interference he
understands how to hit your knee so that
you can't run full speed down the field
on him he understands how to grab your
jersey just a tight tug to pull you into
a break across the middle he has these
little tricks that help him work and so
for me mccreary
it's it's it's not just technical it's
being savvy like this guy is straight up
he's he's a savvy corner and i love when
i watch a game and people are like well
he grabbed him i'm like yeah but he
grabbed him in a way that you can't call
that as past interference from gravity
man it's it's okay if you cheat if you
get away with it nobody cares that's the
difference and it's not cheating it's
just manipulating the rules and let's be
real people the rules against defensive
backs in the nfl right now are absurd so
give them anything they can get away
with all right keeping the board moving
we are still in the technician phase
this is our last member of this group
kobe bryant from cincinnati we talked
about solace gardner and the blue
chippers and felder mentioned
quarterbacks didn't look his way well
guess who the other guy on the guy
across from him was it was kobe bryant a
four-year starter a senior bowl standout
a player with a ball production felder
where that green light really came on in
the latter half of the you know the two
years not the first two years in the
second half of his starting career he
had seven interceptions and 18 passes
broken up in these last two seasons
builder kobe bryant to me reminds me a
little bit of jalen johnson coming out
of utah a couple years ago
he's got you know physicality he's very
patient in coverage he doesn't overreact
to route stems or anything like that so
kobe bryant's the uh we've you and i
have called him the value corner of this
class for quite some time
yeah patience is key and he he's a very
patient football player i love that
about his game and so watching the way
that he doesn't waste steps i think that
he
it's this is going to sound weird but he
plays corner like he play like a
linebacker where he takes his initial
lead steps diagnosis and then goes and
makes plays so kobe bryant's on that
list for me i love that and then again
we know that he was targeted more
because he was corner two and teams were
looking to throw at him and then they
realized oh we shouldn't throw at this
guy either and i guess we're gonna get
to brian cook a little bit later that's
another guy that teams realized they
couldn't throw about but cincinnati
amazing uh connor take us to the
comments before we get into these
physical beasts the cornerback spot
all right this one for major key
underscore c i think is a great
conversation starter felder he said
mcduffie over stingley question mark
belder i think this is one of those
unique moments of the draft where not
all player rankings are the same right
and hear me out and i want to know your
take on this if you're a team that is
going to be running cover one and cover
zero over and over again you're bringing
guys you're leaving corners on an island
and man coverage all the time you are
gonna love derrick stingley he's gonna
be able to run with receivers disrupt
them at the line of scrimmage if you are
a zone team that cares about guys
watching the quarterback planting and
driving downhill tackling pristine
tackling you're gonna lean trent
mcduffie i don't think i think this is a
rare draft conversation where it's not
as cut and dry as this guy is better
than this guy
yeah no i think you're spot on i listen
i'm glad that we showed stingley
tackling because we know he can do it so
if that's the thing that you want him to
do i feel like it's a waste a little bit
because he's so good in coverage but at
the same time if you're a team that's
gonna play cover three and especially i
know you mentioned the seahawks but if
you're a team that is gonna play that
bale three coverage where you you mug up
early and then you you fade away
mcduffie's a better fit for that than
stingley and so that's going to be an
interesting part of this interesting
element to this is what you want to do
because we've seen in the past teams go
bpa right best player available and it
ends up being a corner but that corner
is underserved in their scheme based
upon what they do and i think a lot
about that with like a josh norman right
where he's a guy who
shine in
zone coverage
and then he got traded in or got was a
free agent ended up in a man coverage
scheme and we never heard from him again
mike is am i wrong with that one
no you're not it's amazing how people
could vanish in the nfl and i saw moose
maxwell in the comments say dax hill
should be in the cornerback nickel
cornerback and safety category well
moose maxwell what if i told you you
missed one he's going to be in the
nickel safety category but you're going
to have to sit tight for that one let's
get into the physical cornerbacks before
we move on to those safeties a class
that felder and i absolutely love this
year but looking at these physical
corners andrew booth former five-star
recruit
he's been heard throughout this process
which no no pun intended has hurt him
overall he has not been able to test a
lot of people believe his athleticism
played would have played really well on
on indy
for teams a guy that can do a little bit
of both we've seen him in zone we've
seen him in man
aggressive felder i think aggressive to
a fault at times where he overruns guys
overruns tackles but you see the ball
skills right there andrew booth is one
of the in my opinion high risk
big time reward players in this
secondary group
the the georgia play that we just showed
is my favorite play him tackling james
cook he he takes a gamble coming down
and he
shortcuts the outside block still beats
the block gets a tackle for a loss on
cook
in the backfield in the game ultimately
what was it seven to three i mean he he
did his job this is a guy that will do
his job again we talked about fickle
we've talked about some of the other
defensive back jimmy lake i think brett
venables belongs in that mix and his
defensive backs coach belong in that mix
with guys that teach their players to
play everything the right way he fits
into that zone he does everything right
he understands where he's supposed to be
he understands the risk that he can take
he is not afraid to stick his nose in it
would you get a guy a corner
who's willing
to and listen i'm someone that played
football their whole life i i i've i
played with a guy who my buddy harry who
said
he was a running back that they
converted a corner because he told them
i'm a runner not a blocker
and then once he realized he had to play
corner and had to tackle he was like i
guess i just tackle now booth is a guy
that's like i want to tackle now and he
will stick his nose up get face up form
tackle you i love that about him when
you play with the guy
he's listen what's what dion sanders say
he's like they don't pay to see me
tackle they pay to see me get
interceptions right like
this guy is not that he is someone that
wants to tackle wants to be an enforcer
in cover two your corner set the edge on
you and he can set that edge hard and
force things back to those chase
linebackers that we talked about a week
ago
you see it right there this one from
slipknot 2k shawn says i would love
andrew booth to the eagles when you look
at the eagle selections we know about 15
and 18 it won't be there can he make it
to 51 there's a chance and that would be
a really really nice fit the eagles
definitely got to be in this corner
market and felder i see your eyes
lighting up
it's going to be it's going to be a
little of a scramble if he makes it that
far i think boot's gonna be top 45-ish
pick in this draft speaking of that
another guy that's a little bit all over
the place cair elam from florida
he's fascinating to me felder you watch
him and here he isn't off coverage but
he's somebody that will go nose to nose
with you he has no problem getting hands
on you at the line of scrimmage
and the oddest the crazy thing with elim
is he's so physical
uh without the person at the wide
receiver having the football right he
will play press coverage he will stay in
your hip pocket he is not a good tackler
right now and that's going to make him
in my opinion a little scheme specific
four teams is that something he can work
on at the next level it only gets harder
we see guys like debo samuel out there
making plays but kair ilam for a press
man team he is going to be very high on
those boards and corners always go early
so another top 40 pick my last thing on
him the 2020 film was up there with
anyone in this class 2021 not the same
guy
yeah no i think the big key with kyrie
elam is
he's a denial football player and i'll
be honest i like a denial football
player um one of the things that gave me
the greatest anxiety playing football
was what if they throw the ball to me
what if they throw the ball like in my
zone so what i have to do is make sure
that i make my you know like it's like
with a bear right you make yourself big
so that they can't get the ball to your
guy and they have to look somewhere else
and elim does that really well which is
why he's which is is speaks to what you
mentioned connor he's super aggressive
pre-throw pre-ball pre-ball and it's so
pretty ball coming out to the wide
receiver he's so aggressive in all those
areas that he neutralizes routes and
hey that's a good way to be man don't
you think connor
i think so i mean listen the best way to
make sure you don't have to tackle is to
make sure the football does not come
your way right so i have no problem with
that um elam for me he's i have him
pretty high in this class with the
corners i just think that it's gonna be
fascinating to watch how he's viewed in
terms of different teams that do put a
premium on that so all right kyrie was a
near stereotype for a belichick corner
i totally agree i think new england's
going to be fascinating to watch it 21.
i think they're going to be looking at
linebacker but it would not shock me to
see that be elum sealing in this trap
that's probably the first place he can
come off the board jump in here felder
if you if if nikobi dean and elam are
both on the board right there and you're
the pats
you got to take dean right
yeah they need a linebacker here's where
i get why i pause there felder why i
hesitate so much they love gigantic
linebackers they never play these guys
that are 511
225 230. i mean look at the guys they've
had in the middle of that defense over
the years i just wonder if they're gonna
look for a true mic that they think can
eat in traffic and i'm not saying dean
can't do those things i'm just wondering
if there's a certain threshold there um
you know in terms of size in new england
that maybe doesn't exist anymore but did
exist for the last 15 years
all right moving on we got a taylor
go ahead felder
no no i was gonna say i dig it
especially
you mentioned threshold and that kind of
reset my mind because nick saban
obviously comes from underneath that
belichick threshold and that belichick
tree and saban is a guy that has a
threshold for players that are
positional players in his schemes and
wouldn't wouldn't surprise me belgic had
the same thing let's go to cam taylor
britt nebraska corner love him saw him
in atlanta in like 2016. uh love this
dude this guy gets the job done you see
him there being physical he is
for my money he's a guy that can play
inside in the slot but he also look at
that come downhill and make somebody pay
he is
another one of those guys that i ask why
isn't he playing safety or could he play
safety is that his future because he's
so physical you see him in the blitz
package you see him in the run game but
then we also see him here as an outside
corner and he's someone that just look
at him fight through a block come on
connor this guy is he's a beast
felder this is the one you nailed it
this is the corner to safety conversion
and i know he's lined up at safety this
is gonna be he's not gonna get out there
and look around and go where the hell am
i what planet am i on he's done this
before
it should be his full-time role and i'll
explain why and i mean this is no insult
to his game the weakness of his game is
being sticky in man coverage there's
times where he just gets lost in
transition guys to where any i know he
ran the sub 4-4 but i don't think the
play speed or maybe it's the lateral
agility is up to par with an outside
starting man-to-man corner where why not
maximize his skill set he'd be a great
safety he's a physical tackler like
felder said he's so good with everything
in front of him especially coming
downhill so cam taylor brit a very
physical corner i don't think you can
get creative with him you can play him
too high at times maybe there's times
where you ask him to come down and be a
big nickel run with tight ends run with
big slots because we know he can do that
where he gets in trouble is against
those smaller shiftier guys that can
have him you know just struggling to
stay in coverage so i think you're all
over at felder he's my favorite corner
to safety conversion one
we got a comment here that new camera
got connor looking like the long-lost
jonas brother
oh man i am uh
somebody uh
said yesterday i looked like i was
dressing for a boy band so i think this
is becoming a consistent theme i might
need a makeover all right moving on to
our last physical corner felder the most
interesting one marcus jones because
people are going to look at this guy
he's not even five foot ten he's small
he's one of the most dynamic return men
in the entire country but felder he does
not play like a small corner as you see
on the b roll there we love marcus jones
yeah i mean listen this dude is five
foot eight
and for him to climb the ladder on guys
that are six two six three six four get
a pbu you see the way that he was able
to hit obviously a dynamic return man as
well
he had to go up we were going to put him
in technicians listen
listen i'll peel back the curtain we
were going to put him on technician
because his technique is so crisp but
the reality of it is if you're five foot
eight and you can climb the ladder and
bat balls away from six foot three guys
and you can send those guys flying off
the sideline you gotta go into the
physical category because i think that's
the trait that we've gotta honor the
most
all right yeah i love marcus jones uh i
think he's gonna be one of the best
returners in the nfl and i think he's
gonna hold up in the slot a lot better
than people are expecting all right
looking at the comments
the uh first one from destroyed 66 7
where does alante taylor fault now
felder this is another guy obviously ran
really well four three six forty uh made
significant starts all four years at
tennessee i love him in zone uh you know
i wrote down he gets in trouble a little
bit in man coverage lacks short area
agility just not a sticky we talked
about that a little bit with cam taylor
grit there's not a lot of ball
production on the resume but when you
watch him he can carry receivers deep
with that speed especially playing off
he has the eyes and awareness what have
you seen with delante taylor a guy
that's kind of gotten lost in this
corner class that we didn't talk about
today
yeah no i love i listen i i actually
this is funny i did radio uh two days
ago with jason swain former tennessee
wide receiver he does a radio show
midday did radio we talked about allante
taylor for a little while and i love his
ability to carry and the ability to
carry someone whether you're playing
cover two or you're playing cover three
you have to carry someone from the
outside to the inside and pass them off
i love his communicating communicative
skills and the way that he's able to
carry is important because that plays
again goes back to that denial football
where he's able to take someone and
cover two give you a reroute he'll give
you a reroute then he's gonna carry the
route all the way to the next guy so it
eliminates the void that exists in
between the corner and the safety he
does that really really well and i think
that that's uh that's real value like if
you wanna if we wanna talk in real time
uh one of the best corners ever at doing
that was rondae barber and i think that
he's got that that like rondae barber
doesn't have to be
a million interceptions a year and do
all these things allante taylor doesn't
have to be that either what he has to do
is make sure that they're not throwing
this pass
so that my safety is helped out over the
top
and my safety can get over the top and
he does those little things really
really well with respect to reroute and
carrying guys i think that's the part
where uh you know it doesn't always show
up on no it always shows up on film it
doesn't show up in highlight videos and
that's the part that i think people miss
on
you're all over it felder all right
moving on to the safety
we got one in the blue chip and you guys
know him very very well we've talked
about kyle hamilton
nearly every week on this show and we'll
get through kyle hamilton a little bit
here but we got a deep safety class to
break down
felder
somebody from me that is so good over
the top he's got range he's got these
long strides as a sideline a sideline
tackler he's even built like a
linebacker at times where he could
survive in the box he doesn't get lost
in traffic and the ball skills are real
he's going to make plays on the football
especially with that those long arms
that are so competitive at the catch
point you see him right there bouncing
around and getting into uh behind the
line of scrimmage now it's going to be
fascinating for him to see if he can
still develop in man coverage at the
next level if a team wants to draft him
to be an eraser to take on these kyle
pitts players of the world kyle hamilton
is a great player
yeah no i love him i love the way he
comes down on the boxes we saw on that
play right here you see him mirroring
and then and reading the quarterback to
go rob i love that out of him i think he
can do all those things i think that the
key for me with kyle hamilton there's a
reason he's our blue chip guy he's look
he can do everything you do everything
you want to do he is he's a plused-up
version of what you want to say to me i
think that kyle hamilton personally i
think he's probably a top three top four
player in this nfl draft uh we'll just
have to wait and see where he ends up
absolutely and it's gonna be in the top
15. but let's move on to the box
safeties right and some people take that
as an insult in this era and this was
more for us these are where these guys
look best this first one lewis seen from
georgia he looks good doing a lot of
different things he's much better in
coverage than giving credit for but
felder when this train gets rolling down
the tracks downhill
you do not want to be standing there in
its path lewis seen hits unlike a lot of
guys i've watched at the college level
before and it's clean man it's clean his
range and you're going to see that range
right here are the smarts to stay over
the top and not bite on the cheese make
a play on the football he's an elite
elite athlete and that is going to play
at the next level for a lot of roles but
what he can do coming downhill with the
line of scrimmage is nearly special
he saved the kobe dean's bacon on that
play you see him here making another
play to get the ball out
and then look this guy just he gets it
done and and the big thing for me and
of all the safeties in this draft and
i've i've been looking at these safeties
pretty closely um
because that's just that's my favorite
position of in football i think they're
the smartest guys on the field uh no
disrespect to quarterbacks or centers
but linebackers even but i think
safety's they got to do way more um and
they're doing it all going backwards so
i think the big thing with louisiana is
he's gonna make you pay
he's gonna hurt you
and
when you have that level of enforcer
we've seen it with what like cam
chancellor right when you have that
level of enforcer cam chancellor's a guy
who made a offensive guard in the nfl
complaining about getting hit a little
bit late a safety shouldn't be doing
that and i think lewis got a little bit
of that in his blood so that's the scary
part for me with him because if you get
him coming down it's it's almost like
he's offended that you thought you could
run to where he's ali filling and then
he comes down and guess what
i hope that i hope you got your
checkbook out baby because the rent is
due
yeah man he reminds me of javon holland
who just had a tremendous rookie season
for the miami dolphins last year uh one
of the best defensive rookies in the
entire nfl i think scene plays a very
similar style of game they got play
speed that you could watch football for
12 seconds and you'll recognize it right
away all right our other box safety on
the group smoke monday one of the best
names in this draft now belder he's a
little different from scene from me
because i think this guy is a true box
safety at the next level unlike you know
what scene you're going to ask him to
play too high at times you're going to
ask him to do different things in
coverage with smoke he's somebody that i
really truly do like living near the
line of scrimmage working through
traffic stopping these outside zone runs
being a physical physical tackler that
really forget taking plays off this guy
brings 110 snap after snap after snap
yeah he listen we just watched those
clips he likes to mix it up this guy
likes to be like he's like he he wants
to be a linebacker he's he's someone
who's mad at his parents that he's not
bigger because he wants to play
linebacker so i love the way that smoke
plays he is he's so fun like this is a
guy if you're gonna play cover zero in
short yardage put him in there he's
gonna play that linebacker spot as you
move down to a bear front so yeah i
really like smoke monday from from
auburn to two sec cats uh taking up the
mix and box safeties
all right let's get back to the comments
right now as we dive in it looks like
larry hodges is in there saying in your
opinion are there any players in this
draft with a similar profile to marcus
peters when he was coming out of college
well i got news for you my comparison
for derek stingley marcus peters so to
answer your question it's a very very
simple
yes all right one more here felder dave
danger says kyle hamilton equals cam
chancellor what do you think of that
player comparison
all right listen i i already gave cam
chancellor to lewis scene so i can't do
i can't do that double it up you know
what's crazy i honestly i think that
isaiah spiller and i think kyle hamilton
is a smaller isaiah spiller that you
keep it safety instead of having him
play at linebacker um
thomas davis even like he's that sort of
a football player that can do a bunch of
stuff but i think that you just in
today's nfl instead of having this guy
convert to linebacker you have him play
it safety and keep him at that safety
spot as one of your like big nickel guys
all right i see uh johnny pro says i
want to hear about the baler safeties
petri will be a starter right away and
woods has a ton of potential you're in
the right place time to get into the
nickel safeties you're gonna have to
wait a little bit though for jalen petry
we are starting with daxton hill and
felder we've talked about him on the
show before but truly that dream chess
piece for any defensive coordinator for
a cover guy we've seen him play in the
slot we've seen him play on the back end
ball skills twitch so fluid in coverage
great eyes dax hill to me is a round one
player felder
i i think he's around one guy too you
see him here he's in the slot again
blitz from slot okay cover from slot
sink into zone coverage right there to
rob uh to rob the route uh you see him
here coming across the formation in man
coverage outraged the guy to the to the
sideline to make a tackle for loss or
tackle for minimal gain i again line up
in the slot bail out you look at that
little slice action baby where they're
exchanging responsibilities i love to
see those things happen so yeah jackson
hill is a great chess piece um i called
him a swiss army knife before uh i think
that he he can play outside corner
inside corner he can play single high he
can play too high he's done all those
things in his career he's done them very
well he's a great tackler he is a
physical ball player
i think that for me
and again maybe this is some safety bias
but i think he's a top 20 player in this
draft maybe top 18
i think he's super good and i love
watching him play so daxton hill is our
first guy on that list
uh connor you want to take us to brian
cook because brian cook's another safety
that i think i just like him way more
than other people
yeah he's awesome though i mean he
reminds me of tony jefferson coming out
of oklahoma where
he's just such a physical player but
felder get this from my friends at pff
350 plus snaps in the box this year 186
snaps in the slot 281 playing free
safety there's just nothing this guy
can't do
for a defense that was loaded with star
talent he would go fill the void
wherever it was needed and it was so
impressive to me to watch him play out
in the slot not give anything up in
coverage and then also be willing to
come down and make a hit and he hits
with
violence and it once again it's he
understands how to hit with violence i
think that's something we need to
distinguish in today's nfl we love big
hits but you got to be smart with it you
don't want to get yourself thrown out of
the game you want to give yourself
15-yard penalties nobody likes that in
football so if you understand how to
bring it set the tone on the field in a
clean way that makes big plays for your
team brian cook is just tremendous at
that man
yeah i know i love him i and the thing i
love is in here
his diagnosis ability is remarkable
because there are they were almost an
exclusive man defense right so when he's
single high he knows i got to help my
linebackers to help my other safety to
help my corners last which is why sauce
and kobe bryant were so good because
they were the last guys to get help
but when you look at him he also
recognized
i got to come down to ali phil i have to
diagnose run first and so while i'm
looking at who i'm helping the next
thing that i'm doing the next thing that
i'm processing as a smart football
player is
oh the guy that i'm covering just went
across to block so he's sealing the
defensive end as he seals the defensive
end where's the trouble coming from the
trouble's coming from the other side
because they don't want him to get to
this side so i'm going to come down and
make this tackle i think he's one of the
best tacklers at the at the safety spot
in this class he is
he there's a there's a there's a
multiplicity to his game from a zone man
and then obviously tackling run
enforcement stand uh standpoint that
works really really well so i i i connor
you know you know i love him i'm a big
brian cook guy when we when we pre like
you know months ago when we were talking
about this i was like i gotta make sure
we talk about brian cook just cause i
love like watching him was truly
enjoyable
yeah i can't wait to be sitting next to
you when he gets drafted for our live
coverage of bleach report it's gonna be
it's gonna be a moment for everybody and
i think the audience that watches crash
course and watches our draft coverage
will share that one with us uh johnny
pro says daxil reminds me of tyron
matthew but less ball production coming
out reminds me of malcolm jenkins same
body type same athletic profile
you know that's
honey badger is a little smaller than
dax hill but i definitely get to i
understand what he's saying seeing that
energy on the field all right let's talk
about jalen petry popular player in the
comments uh popular player for the last
couple months now i thought he was one
of the best players on the field during
senior bowl practices this is where he
lives folks you see him right there in
the slot he'll come downhill makes a
play on the ball there but that's not
what he was notable for he was notable
for his smash mouth ability against the
run against screens really just a
violent slot option
a violent box player
smart tough physical plays fast throws
his weight around felder just loves the
way he throws his weight around he can
fly he can absolutely fly reminds me of
jordan whitehead he's been a great
player coming out of pit for the bucks
just got a big money contract from the
new york jets these slender guys that
can run and they don't hit like they're
190 pounds they hit like they're 230
pounds
yeah i listen on the clip i love the
fact that he's pointing things out so
many times when you watch him play you
see him point things out you see him
talk to people say hey hey hey hey hey
and it's it's the idea of him playing
whether it's playing levels or playing
um uh playing levels or playing man
coverage or recognizing i don't want to
get caught up in the watch he can run
that nickel iso blitz which allows him
to get into the backfield and go make a
play and rush to the interior to that b
gap
he's not afraid which is great so yeah
he belongs in that nickel zone i think
that like in theory people would see him
as a box safety but the reality is he's
out of the box he's playing over the
slot he's playing over that flexed out
tight end and then he's able to come
into the box to go make those plays
all right let's uh take into the
comments here jay bernatoic says just
how far off are guys like lewis seen in
daxton hill from kyle hamilton
man i think it's closer than a lot of
people want to admit i really do i know
it's it's not been a popular take in
this trap i have kyle hamilton as the
eighth overall player in the strap scene
21 dax hill 23. i think it's a really
really good safety class so if your team
is not picking the top 15 you don't get
kyle hamilton
they're different players right felder
than kyle hamilton but they're guys that
they impact the game in a lot of
different ways dax hill more on the
coverage side seeing more on the smash
mouth side what do you think
no i think you're right i don't think
that there's a humongous gap
but i do think that all these safeties
that we're talking about are really good
and that's the part for me that's
interesting
like if i'm being honest
i would probably rank four of these
safeties ahead of any of the
quarterbacks in terms of where i have
them in this draft
yep i have
those three ahead of any of the
quarterbacks and then jaquan brisker
just right behind malik willis and kenny
pickett so and once again
they get the curve on they get the
quarterback curve i want to make people
on the show and then are gonna watch our
draft coverage aware of this the
quarterback curve is real okay so let's
uh let's be let's be weary of that all
right let's keep this moving because
this is a deep class we want to get
through as many players as we can we're
trying to get through as many players as
we can for everyone without cutting
anyone out the ball hawk safeties and
builder i'm going to toss this one right
to you verone mckinley from oregon
he's not we've talked about this on the
phone he's not big
he's not fast
but man he's a damn good football player
he knows what's gonna happen before it
happens we talked about this with the
kobe dean watch him on this play he's
already moving moving moving okay i know
where i gotta go i'm gonna get there no
problem
i get there like i know where i have to
be pre-snapped to make the quarterback
think he can throw it here and then i go
this way to make sure i can go make a
play him coming downhill look at the
alley phil both go ahead and deliver a
blow even if he's not a big guy look at
him mirroring the quarterback in the
scramble drill go take the ball away i
love vero mckinley i saw him in texas
shout out to our buddy sean mcmanus who
um
he left me at the hotel didn't pick me
up and i had to just take an uber to the
event because mcmanus forgot to pick me
up to take me um but that's where i saw
roe mckinley he was a quiet kid him
coming out of his shell at oregon has
been amazing he's so good moving from
corner to safety has been a huge benefit
to him he has the range that you want
out of a safety that ball hawk skill
that ability to see things before they
happen is critical he is the opposite
of um who do we talk about on the call
marcus williams right from utah he's the
opposite of that a guy who he knows
what's going to happen before it happens
and so he doesn't have to have the same
athleticism that we've seen the utah guy
have what he has is instincts in this
this film study that gives him a leg up
and we see the same thing with the kobe
dean he's doing that in the back end
all right now we'll talk about a guy
that's on the completely other end of
the spectrum and nick cross from
maryland he is big he is fast six feet
212 pounds four three four speed my
goodness builder this guy can fly 37
inch vertical jump i mean he is an elite
athlete there's no way around it now
what i'll say here felder for all those
great things and big time splash plays
he's not as instinctual and not as
seasoned as a guy like mckinley but when
he does see it felder or even sometimes
when he's a hair late he's got the
makeup speed to get it done
yeah and the recovery is the big thing
for him he has that in spades and
he he um
he reminds me of a guy that played
offense all the time and then found out
that he could make probably more money
playing defense and just decided to do
that or that's where his team needed the
help from but he he's
i want him to learn more about whether
it's the film watching or the the
understanding of
how things work or how people can hurt
you and he's we see flashes of it
consistently right and we're seeing flat
excuse me inconsistently we see flashes
uh what we want are for those flashes to
become his consistent game and that's
what i'm looking forward to because when
you have this
it's it's when you have these raw
ingredients you can make a great meal
it's just about being always able to
produce that meal which means you got to
follow a recipe and that's what i'm
looking for from nick cross
all right felder let's close this thing
out with somebody that in our eyes has
put it all together man it's not the
ingredients you got the filet mignon
sitting right there jaquan brisker i
mean my goodness and i know a lot of his
plays are him doing this coming down in
the box reading the run flying through
the line of scrimmage he had a shoulder
injury week one that he played through
the rest of the season and it did lead
to him having to tackle differently
having to play differently he gutted
through it but felder we put him in the
ball hawking safeties for a reason
we just love the versatility that this
guy has the movement ability on the back
end what have what have you seen from
brisker so far that's going to
transition to the next level
i i love him man like this dude this is
one of those dudes that like gets me
emotional
emotional about football like he is you
mention the shoulder injury he played
through the shoulder injury this is a
guy that's a fighter he's a brawler
he can play deep safety i think the co
the two like the three plays that stand
out to me with respect to jaquan brisker
uh won in the wisconsin game to start
the year watching him play a linebacker
and cover zero and then come across in
the hole and he does give up they give
up the first down but he's able to chop
down chesmar lucy before he scores a
touchdown and i love that as a guy
that's a safety plan in the box next
play for me would be playing cover zero
his guy blocks he sinks into the hole
and he's able to get an interception to
kill the wisconsin game
then they play auburn right and against
auburn now we're talking about umbrella
coverage right we've got you've got
umbrella he's up over the top and he's
played in that deep middle which is why
he goes into that ball category i know
he wanted to get an interception to end
the game against auburn but he was able
to get a pass breakup that ultimately
killed the game for them and so his
ability to move around do everything and
he's one of the main reasons why i get
so mad about people talking about fake
injuries i was like this guy's been hurt
for 10 weeks
maybe it's gonna take him a little bit
of time to get up off the ground my man
yeah he got it through it and it's you
know there's a lot of missed tackles on
tape that are clearly because of it it's
not the player that he is and i hope
people
are made aware of that it reminds me of
eric weddle a guy that just did
everything for so long whatever was
asked of him he he can play in coverage
he can roam he can come downhill he can
run with tight ends he can play in the
slot he can do it all and brisker is
going to have a long nfl career as long
as he could stay healthy jump in here
a little bit of jim leonard right the
guy for the ravens like
yeah like just a super smart football
player that understands where they're
supposed to be all the time and they're
super versatile so yeah jim leonard too
who's now i guess is he the defensive
coordinator of wisconsin so yeah there
we go he certainly is that smart's
carried over to a healthy coaching
career as well all right let's take a
look at the comments uh felder slipknot
tk shawn says i'm interested to see more
of this kid mckinley looks like a hell
of a player well we're excited to break
him down and grade that pick on draft
night as well donovan mcswag says nick
cross is going to be a beast he's going
to be one of the biggest risers in this
draft i think nick cross can go in the
first 75
picks all right let's keep this thing
moving we got to close it out nfc south
break down our final divisional preview
of draft crash course
2022.
let's kick things off right here with a
little team needs we got the panthers we
got the falcons we got the saints and
tom brady is back with the bucks in case
you didn't hear right now in case you've
been uh in a long slumber so felder i
know you're a charlotte guy always a lot
of noise around the panthers and with
them picking in the top ten more noise
than ever i'm going to kick things off
here and look at a deep cut how many
times felder can we talk about malik
willis and kenny pick it at the sixth
overall pick over and over and over
again panthers fans i know you're tired
of it we're not doing it today so i'm
looking at pick 144 149 devonte price at
a fiu now
i know you're thinking mccaffrey's there
i know you're thinking shuba hubbard's
the backup
mccaffrey is hurt every year shubar
hubbard is also a guy that traditionally
gets hurt every year you always need to
be three deep at running back felder
devante price is unlike anything they
have six foot two four three speed he's
just a ball of clay at the running back
position he can make you miss he can
play big he's got the tree trunk legs
he's got the breakaway speed these are
the kind of running backs felder that i
bet on on day three elite size elite
athleticism sure the college production
isn't there because nobody on that
offensive line could block anything in
front of them but i would bet on him
what do what do you think of price and
what do you got for the panthers as we
do our day three picks for them
i know i like price i think he's a good
player listen this is a guy obviously
fiu and uh butch the butch davis
connection there i i'm always in on that
my boy brynne renner i was on staff
there for a while so yeah i'm in but for
me i'm gonna go date three pick i'm
going to wreak wollen and i think that
it's insane that he ran a 4-3-40
and the fact that when you watch it you
realize that this guy is like six foot
four he's willing to tackle he could
make plays i think that he's a great fit
for a team that is still looking to
shore up that secondary uh he's physical
and
just the length is something that you
want from that cornerback spot
man he is
you want to talk about someone we've
really never seen before in that
capacity
mullen is unreal six foot four four
three speed he's still learning he's
still figuring it out but it is truly
insane to see that level of athlete with
that kind of size at the position if a
team can give him a red shirt-ish kind
of year they don't throw him to the fire
let him develop on his own
he can be unlike something we've seen at
the corner position with that
measurables all right let's keep this
moving obviously uh we did the panthers
without doing quarterback a minor
miracle in itself we're into the falcons
as well and even with matt ryan gone
marcus mariota we're not looking at
quarterback here either i'm gonna start
this one off a little bit easy felder
pick eight garrett wilson i just don't
want the falcons to overthink this one
you need a wide receiver he's someone
that's kind of this ironically calvin
ridley cd lamb blend a smooth operator
knows how to get open excellent body
control at the catch point juice after
the catch to break a tackle you're gonna
see a stiff arm here that's gonna send a
guy all the way to hell i mean he he's
got it felder he can be a number one
wide receiver at the next level i like
what garrett wilson could do before the
catch at the catch and after the catch
yeah listen he's great in all of those
phases i think that he's i think he's
probably going to end up being the first
wide receiver off the board uh and yeah
why not the falcons this is going to be
interesting because
listen with the calvin ridley betting
fiasco situation they need somebody
right now which you know what's scary
about this is if they get him being able
to have both of those guys is gonna be
pretty nice for them
so that's gonna that's gonna be
interesting me i go a little bit deeper
i'm going to that i guess it's round two
maybe round three but probably round two
i'm gonna go troy anderson we talked
about him a week ago as a linebacker
that can be an every down backer and we
know the falcons want a little bit of
help at that spot uh so i'm gonna go
with our guy from what is it montana
state like we've got an opportunity to
to to shore up that defense to make
things work i i'm going with troy
anderson as a guy that just he can be a
tracker on that defense
man one of the most interesting players
in the entire draft right you're talking
about an all-conference quarterback some
of his best film is playing running back
and now he's found a home at linebacker
and a projected top 60 pick in the draft
so troy anderson
man he he's this ball of clay running
chase backer cover three scheme that can
do it all and it's gonna be a lot of fun
to watch his growth at the next level
all right let's move on to the saints
felder i'm going to throw this one to
you first they're picking at 16 they're
picking at 19.
what what's your uh your dream scenario
for the saints in the first round here
so here's the this is here's the thing
is kyle hamilton going to be there
that's a chance that's the part
that's the scary that's this
it's frustrating for me but oh by the
way i love this play look at him he's on
the hash let's go get on your horse
i'll take that one away baby let's go i
love that play but no
is he gonna be there at 16. if he's
there at 16
can you not take
if he's that sick if kyle hamill is
available at 16 conor can you not take
him
no you have to take him you have to now
and now i know people are going to say
oh
you know they paid marcus may or what no
you take kyle hamilton you still they
still need a safety that you know they
lost marcus williams who ironically we
talked about earlier on this show
they still need a safety he's too
talented i know they need a tackle i
know they need a wide receiver
that would be a tough one to pass up now
i'm looking later on in this draft maybe
towards pick 98 and i'm looking at the
most underrated pass rusher in the
entire draft and that's d'angelo malone
from western kentucky and honestly
felder if this guy was six foot four and
weighed 255 pounds everybody would be
all over him but he's not the bend uh
the twitch the change of direction
i don't really care that he's small if
he has to be a situational pass rusher
early on you take that guy at 98 and you
run with that over and over again so
d'angelo malone reminds me a little bit
of vic beasley coming out a good athlete
maybe not for everybody maybe not a set
the edge early down run defender but if
you need somebody to get you off the
field on third and long you let him rush
wide you let him turn the corner into
the pocket and he gets the job done and
i think the saints marcus davenport's
gonna have to be paid soon they've
gotten a little old at a couple
positions peyton turner didn't give them
anything last year this is how you get
some value
so what's the what's the gap between
malone and a guy like nick benito what's
the gap between those guys
for me felder it is dang close i have
d'angelo malone as the 41st best player
in this draft i know i'm i'm very high
on him and benito at 58. so they are
round two guys to me that are gonna come
on the field early on they're gonna be
third down guys and if you can get them
in an nfl weight program add a little
mass a little more hand technique maybe
they can develop into full-time players
on first and second down as well i love
both of them nick benito hassan reddick
clone to me there's a place in this pass
happy league for guys like that and it's
not on the scrap heap it's it's nearing
a premium to get off those get off the
field on those downs so
all right one team left
we saved tom brady for last um so we got
the bucks here on the clock and you and
i are not looking at pick 27 in this
draft because once again it's a crash
course introducing new players i'm going
to cheat a little bit i'm going to use
this time to talk a little more about a
guy we introduced today and nick cross
from maryland nick cross to me with the
bucks at let's say pick 60 here felder
cause i don't think he makes it to 91
man if there's anything i know about
todd bowles from his time in the nfl his
time with the new york jets and now his
time with the bugs he loves having a
plethora of talented athletic
play-making safeties felder this is
someone who drafted jamal adams and
marcus may in back-to-back rounds one
year first and second round i don't care
that they have antoine winfield i don't
care that they sign logan ryan to play
in the slot they're going to be losing
defensive backs to free agency in 2023.
nick cross is the
all athlete but if anyone can develop
him into a superstar todd bowles has an
excellent track record of doing that and
he's always looking for his next safety
every single year
i love that i am
i'm gonna stay practical man look tom
brady ain't moving around okay
he going nowhere if if somebody gets a
chance to hit him they're going to hit
him so i'm going to go with a guard i'm
going to go with an interior offensive
lineman i'm going there mumford from
ohio state i'm looking at him and when
you watch
when you watch him play i think he just
he's well taught he's methodical he's
got that wide base the ability to anchor
i think he's going to be able to come in
and
really be kind of a plug and play guy
like where do you need him you need me
left guard you need a minute right guard
what can he do he can move he's played
some tackle i think he's going to kick
down inside to start his career and
we'll see where he goes from there but
this is someone that's played a couple
different positions and we talked about
it with jamari sawyer we've talked about
it with evan neal we've talked about
with these other players
that versatility is important and so for
me i'm going there mumford as a guy just
at the end of the day
when you're carrying you know what are
you would he carry eight offensive
linemen nine offensive lineman he's
someone that if something happens we can
put him in at one of these positions and
kick things around and still have an
opportunity to play for a super bowl
all right felder here's the recap of the
team needs looking at the comment
section now
let's keep this moving johnny pro said
matt corral and crystal lave to the
saints atl says falcon's dream tibbs
falls that's one to number eight that
might be called a dream for a reason but
i've been wrong before belder i'll toss
this one to you jay bernatowicz says who
is the most underrated safety in this
trap is there anybody you want to see
this is your chance fella you could
sneak someone in on the show that we
didn't get to or you could pick from the
group of guys that we got to go over on
the crash course today
i i think for i think the answer is vero
mckinley like the more i watch him like
i've been doing some writing about these
safeties and everyone i usually just do
two videos on mckinley i got three
videos on him and it's just but i guess
i could also go with with brisker
because brisker like brisker's on that
cat full-on kevin gates like i got six
jobs i don't get tired like he does his
whole thing like
man i oh ah
i look i
i just i really love watching all these
guys play like i'm
it's it's this is it's been a treat to
do this show conor because i love
watching all these dudes get down and
get after it nick cross is another one
where like
the guy is just he can be everywhere if
we can just find a way to get him
pointed in the right direction he can be
everywhere all the time like this guy's
just he could be a superhero it's so
it's crazy to think about
how oh oh
who's the kid from illinois the illinois
guy that's who i'm going to say is
underrated
yes kirby joseph he's a little short but
this dude he brings the wood and he's
got good range yes kirby joseph that's
who i will go with as the most
underrated safety
i like it felder i like it i'll give you
one more here juanya thomas uh from
georgia tech as well this is a
he's so good he's so good one is so good
man he's so good the way that he moves
the way he moves side to side is amazing
i love that i love him coming down into
the box
see you see how excited i'm getting now
like like i got excited about kevin
joseph then you bring up juanite thomas
and i'm like oh yeah this he's also very
good like it just
i love these dudes they're good they're
really good we can do it all day this
safety class is awesome that's why we
saved this show
for kind of last you see it down there
monday we will be back because next week
next thursday is the draft and i'll get
to that in a minute we are back on
monday it is our finale it's the mock
draft special so tune in with felder and
i as we do our mock draft special monday
at 1 pm eastern time but better yet do
not miss this we are live for the nfl
draft on day one on day two
and on day three we are covering all of
the picks from rounds one through five
and it's gonna be me adam lefkow of
course felder all in studio together in
br new york city and we've got some
special guests joining us as well that
have been on an nfl field quite recently
and it's more than one but i won't give
away those names yet but it's gonna be
really exciting our draft coverage uh
it's my favorite thing we do here felder
and us being reunited we're gonna have a
grand old time grading every single pick
you see it on the board right there one
more reminder it's not just day one it's
not just day two we'll be back on
saturday we'll piece ourselves together
with a cup of coffee and be ready to go
all right everyone thanks so much for
tuning into the crash course we'll catch
you next week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]